bonjour à tous on a parlé il ya quelques
jours du nouvel ipad de 2018 l'ipad 9,7
pouces et ça nous en sommes à nous poser
la question qu'est l'ipad choisir en
2018 et s'en va le regarder maintenant
[Musique]
la gamme ipad est quand même une gamme
qui est très très très large alors c'est
vrai que depuis le premier ipad en 2010
et de l'eau qui a coulé sous les ponts
il ya de plus en plus de produits et y
en a tellement que c'est un petit peu
compliqué de savoir qu'elle achetait
alors bien évidemment les modèles
antérieurs
c'est pas la peine de souffler dessus
parce que forcément il va être obsolète
ne serait-ce qu'au niveau de l'eau est
ce au niveau des applications
et si vous faites la mise à jour
forcément ça va ramer par contre la
question se pose à savoir quel modèle
acheté entre les modèles de 2018
le modèle en tout cas de may 18 2010 est
2016 et même 2015
il ya pas mal de produits ce qu'on va
faire dans cette vidéo c'est qu'on va
dégrossir un petit peu tout ça regardez
ce qui est intéressant ce qu'il faut
acheter à qui s'adressent ces ipad
est-ce qu'ils sont intéressants pour
vous et au final qu'est l'ipad d'acheter
en 2018 dans un premier temps que
demanderait de marquer en commentaire
vous qu'à l'ipad vous avez si vous en
avez un est ce que vous avez en projet
d'en acheter un
est ce que ça vous intéresse oui non
avant même qu'on parle un petit peu
courant dans le sujet et à la même
occasion était mené cette jolie pouces
comme ça on est au top
allez on y va alors on va commencer tout
de suite pas faire un petit bref résumé
des ipad j'ai tout beau c'est bien sûr
j'ai mes fiches et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'on va faire un
petit peu un petit tour ont un peu
l'historique parce que le premier ipad
première génération tout premier est
sorti en 2010 alors je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez moi en tout cas quand le
premier ipad est sorti je me suis dit
c'est quoi ce truc ce truc seraient en
fin de compte un espèce de gros iphone
ne peut pas téléphoner avec ça me sert
simplement à rien mais on se rend compte
qu entre nos mains qu'en manipulant
c'est pas un gros iphone ça une vraie
utilité et c'est comme ça qu'on se rend
compte vraiment de l'intérêt des
tablettes
alors aujourd'hui on voit qu'avec
l'apparition des styles et quelle que
soit la marque avec l'apparition des
claviers qu'on peut brancher en plus on
arrive davantage sur une tablette et on
se rapproche tout doucement d'un
ordinateur personnel alors effectivement
d'un point de vue historique le premier
ipad est arrivé en 2010 l'ipad 2 2011 le
premier ipad 2 les u17 bon ça marche
très très bien à l'époque
à l'époque le nouvel ipad la troisième
génération en 2012
on sait que vous avez eue l'ipad r en
2013 l'ipad r 2 en 2014
ensuite l'ipad cinquième génération en
l'ipad 2018 le 9,7 pouces qui est
annoncée ya pas très longtemps par apple
lors d'une conférence sur l'éducation à
chicago à l'ipad mini qui arrivait de
l'an 2013 le mini ii
2014 le mini 3 2015 le mini 4 2016 et
l'ipad pro 2015-2016 donc il ya beaucoup
d' ipad y en a encore pas mal sur le
marché que ce soit sur le marché du neuf
sur le marché de l'occasion donc d'où
l'intérêt de faire cette vidéo pour un
petit feu des grosses ya l'histoire
alors vous allez voir en finalité c'est
pas si compliqué que ça
on va isoler de gamme on va isoler la
gamme pro dans un budget assez
conséquent quand même
et de notre côté la gamme un peu plus
grand public comme le chroniquer senti
ya pas longtemps à l'ipad 9,7 pouces de
2018 alors la gamme pro pour regarder
vous avez aujourd'hui en tout cas dans
les produits qui sont intéressants
deux tailles d'écran qu'il faut vraiment
retenir vous avez l'écran de 10 points 5
pouces et l'écran de 12,9 pouces la
question à se poser c'est l'utilité
c'est la toute première chose au delà de
parler du prix au delà de parler tout ça
l'utilité pour moi la gamme pro s
adressent vraiment aux designers aux
infographistes aux architectes à des
personnes qui ont besoin très précis
d'un apple pencil d'avoir vraiment un
écran plutôt grand on va pas se mentir
avec un point de détail vraiment que ce
soit au niveau du style et au niveau de
l'écran pour harris aux deux très très
juste
donc on s'adresse vraiment à toute cette
catégorie à toute cette population à mon
avis à 3.20 sur la gamme pro pour
vraiment savoir faire son choix
le tout premier effectivement c'est la
taille de l'écran 19 5 pouces 12,9
pouces
de quoi avez vous besoin avez vous
besoin d'attendre un petit peu plus
grand quand même un douzième 9 pouces on
va pas se mentir avec le cadre à côté
c'est comme un produit qui as et mastoc
mais qui quand vous allez travailler
dessus va être vraiment très agréable
ça évite de s'abîmer les yeux donc ça
c'est vraiment la question à se poser 10
5 12 19
bon ça dépend un petit peu de votre
utilité à mon avis si vous faut pas
forcément un produit compact un peu
petit un peu réduit le 12,9 est vraiment
bien alors forcément plus cher mais vous
permettra de travailler dans des
conditions qui seront beaucoup plus
agréable sans vous faire mal aux yeux
sans vous fatiguer et puis surtout
quelque chose effectivement
esthétiquement qui est beaucoup mieux
qui a vraiment peu plus de gueule
ensuite le deuxième point c'est la
capacité de stockage au plus bas à 64
giga au plus haut 512 giga de quelle
capacité avez-vous
- parce que de toute façon ces modèles
ne sont pas extensibles vous pouvez pas
juste rajouter de carte micro sd donc
dès lors que vous avez un modèle 64
gigas si vous avez besoin de plus de
capacité de stockage vous ne pourrez pas
en avoir mis à part stockées dans le
cloud sinon vous allez être bloquées
rapidement mettait donc posé ou vraiment
cette question avant d'aller acheter un
produit surtout s'ils travaillent sur
des projets qui sont tout de suite un
petit peu plus gourmand soit de la
création nous travailler avec des
fichiers haute définition il va vous
falloir des capacités de stockage
si vous voulez garder votre projet en
interne directement dans votre bécane
donc posé vous vraiment la question de
la capacité de stockage parce qu'à mon
avis c'est vraiment un point très très
très important et déterminant dans votre
choix et autres points c'est le modèle
wifi ou alors le modèle wifi + 4 g
effectivement il existe les deux si vous
travaillez dans une enceinte fermée dans
un bureau vous avez le wifi c'est pas
forcément besoin du modèle cellular
modèle avec 4 g par contre si vous vous
déplacez beaucoup si vous allez en
clientèle si vous travaillez à
l'extérieur et vous avez besoin d'une
collectivité
vous avez besoin d'internet ça peut être
intéressant d'avoir un modèle 4g
une fois que vous avez un petit peu
élucider ces trois points vous avez déjà
le portrait robot de votre machine parce
que il faut que sa voix qu'en termes de
budget on est seule chose qui ken assez
élevée alors regardez je vous ai fait un
petit un petit récap on va prendre au
plus bas l'ipad pro 10 5 pouces le
modèle wifi 64 giga coûte 739 euros
et si vous arrivez sur le plus gros hui
fil 4g toujours sur le 19 5 pouces en
512 giga vous êtes à 1289 euros donc
voyez il ya un monde quand même
alors on regarde maintenant du côté du
12,9 pousse le plus bas 64 giga wifi 909
euros et le plus gros huit filles
puissent 4g 512 giga 1459 euros si vous
voulez rajouter l'apple pencil 99 euros
plus le smart qui bordent 179 euros ça
vous fera quand même un modèle à 1747
euros autant vous dire qu'il faut pas se
planter parce que tout de suite c'est un
gros budget bon après d'un point de vue
père c'est vraiment des bonnes machines
vous avez processeur à 10x fusion qui
marche très bien
une caméra à l'arrière de 12 mégapixels
avec une ouverture de f 1.8 assez
lumineux ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal
vous pouvez filmer en 4k vous avez une
stabilisation optique de l'image donc ça
c'est plutôt bien aussi
l'écran retina pour le 10.5 poussins
2002 124 par 1668 pixels et pour le
12.97 à 2732 par 2048 pixels
bon ça fait la faire c'est vraiment bien
très agréable
mouassa des produits qui marchent bien
en plus des autres produits que vous
avez sur les gammes un peu plus grand
public
vous avez le trou tonnes vous avez un
revêtement antireflet vous avez un écran
laminé voile il ya pas mal de choses et
surtout vous avez les smart connector ce
qui fait que vous pouvez brancher votre
clavier directement avec les smartphones
hector à la différence d'un produit
comme celui qui est sorti cette année le
sac de 9,7 pouces de 2018 ou là par
contre vous pouvez effectivement mettre
un clavier par contre c'est un clavier
bluetooth il ya pas de smart collector
dessus donc c'est tous ces petits points
qu'il faut prendre en considération donc
voilà pour moi l'ipad pro on est sur un
produit vraiment destiné comme son nom l
indique aux professionnels maintenant
notre côté vous avez la gamme plutôt
grand public qui effectivement sa
destinée que ce soit aux étudiants aux
personnes qui veulent un une tablette
apple ou à monsieur et madame tout le
monde donc vous avez effectivement le
modèle de 2017 qui est plutôt pas mal
9,7 pouces au niveau de l'écran et le
modèle de 2018 ces deux modèles que tout
de suite je retiens principalement le
modèle de 2018 le 9,7 pouces alors la
grande grande grande différence entre
ces deux produits vont regarder eu des
jarres du point de vue de la performance
parce que sur le modèle de 2010 7 vous
avez un processeur à 9 sur le modèle de
2018 vous avez un processeur à 10 a
discusion qu'on retrouve dans les iphone
7 et dans les iphone c'est plus quelque
chose qui rend forcément un peu plus
vite
vous allez pouvoir être un peu plus
tranquille au niveau de la réalité
augmentée
bon c'est plutôt pas mal si vous voulez
un produit qui va durer un peu plus dans
le temps en terme de mise à jour d'os et
d'applications un peu plus gourmandes
mieux vaut aller sur le modèle de 2018
d'autant plus quand différence de prix
est bien n'a pas eu les produits sont
vendus au même prix voire un petit peu
moins cher pour le modèle de 2018 autre
point de différence sur monde 2018 vous
pouvez utiliser l'apple pencil alors
effectivement il faut rajouter 99 euros
pour la voir vous avez aussi la
possibilité d'utiliser un clavier en
bluetooth comme je vous disais mais
surtout la vraie différence c'est ça à
mon avis c'est l'apple pencil si par
exemple vous êtes étudiant vous vous
aimez griffonné vous aimé dessiner c'est
votre passion puis pas forcément un côté
professionnel donc on va pas tout de
suite allé acheter directement un ipad
prod vous acheter un ipad de 2018 avec
un appel pencil à 99 euros en plus vous
allez avoir un produit qui est très bien
alors vous allez moindre le point de
détail vous allez à moins avoir un écran
hyper confortable pas le trou tonnes pas
de choses comme ça mais ça permettra
déjà d'avoir un très bon produit et de
pouvoir je dirais
travailler avec un stylet sur un ipad à
des coups tout de suite un peu moindre
parce que c'est en rêve en termes de
tarifs l'ipad de 2018 le 9,7 pouces vous
avez deux modèles le wifi ou leur wifi +
4 g 32 gigas ou 128 giga sur le modèle
wifi en 32 gigas et 1 359 euros 128
gydja 449 et l'autre le wifi + 4 g 32
gigas 489 et c'en est une giga 579 et
bien évidemment ce modèle là il a un
grand intérêt s'est rajouté la pulp and
see donc 99 euros de plus
donc tout de suite si vous partez sur la
plus petite config wifi 32 gigas plus
apple pencil 359 +99 vous êtes à 458
euros
bon c'est pas cadeau cadeaux mais au
final vous avez par contre un produit
qui est très bien avec un aveugle pencil
alors effectivement après l'aipac de
2017 vous le retrouverez aujourd'hui les
tarifs
un petit peu plus bas par rapport à ce
que vous trouviez lorsqu'elle a été
lancée le 30 de julian wifi coûte
aujourd'hui 3 139 99 contre 409 euros
forcément il faut bien baisser les prix
pour s'indigner un peu par rapport au
tarif du produit de 2018
on est obligé parce que si on se produit
ne se vendra pas surtout quand même
qu'il est moins performant dont il faut
bien un petit peu écouler des stocks
vous avez aussi les un ipad
l'ipad mini le 7,9 pouces qui existent
alors à mon avis l'ipad mini se destine
davantage à ceux qui veulent vraiment
des petits écrans parce que
fondamentalement en termes de tarifs je
vois pas l'intérêt d'acheter ce produit
il est plus cher en tout cas en modèles
neufs un chez des revendeurs classiques
que l'ipad de 2018 mise à part un tout
petit format un truc hyper contacts
qu'il faut pas trop l'intérêt de se
positionner dessus après il existe aussi
l'ipad r de 2014 qui est toujours sans
marcher le 9,7 pouces mais c'est pareil
le mode wifi en neuf coûte quand même
plus cher que le modèle de données 18
affectivement d'occasion ou ses synthés
revendeurs vous allez trouver un peu
moins cher voire carrément moins cher
mais un produit de 2014 je suis pas sûr
que c'est très intéressant parce que de
toute façon votre puce a pas être la
dernière génération
c'est un produit qui va vieillir
beaucoup moins bien
lorsque vous les faire la mise à jour de
l'ios moment vous allez être limitées
vous n'allez pas pouvoir et les
dernières applications
vous n'allez pas les avoir si vous en
avez certaines elles risquent de ramener
au bout d'un moment sur des budgets sont
calmes tout de suite conséquent donc à
mon avis il existe vraiment deux mots
dell à retenir d'un côté la gamme
professionnelle avec les questions je
vous ai posé tout à l'heure par rapport
à votre utilisation et par rapport à vos
besoins réels à vous et puis cet ipad de
2018 qui vient petit peu rend encore
plus obsolètes les autres puisque vous
avez la possibilité d'utiliser l'apple
peel et ça s'est vraiment bien surtout
que le produit à la base est vraiment
très accessible en terme de budget donc
dans l'absolu si vous avez déjà un ipad
de 2017
n'achetez pas l'ipad de 2018 parce que
sont quand même relativement proche même
si effectivement vous pouvoir l'apple
pencil sur l'impasse au lot même si
effectivement vous et sur la dernière
génération de processeurs des ipad
dessus bon voila mais si vous n'avez pas
besoin d'un apple peine s'il n'allait
pas dessus si par contre l'appel pencil
un vrai sens pour vous vous pouvez y
aller vous allez pas forcément de
l'argent en revendant en achetant le
deuxième mais au moins vous pourrez
utiliser le stylet d'apple
si par contre vous avez un modèle
antérieur 2016 2015 2014 n'en parlons
pas là effectivement ça peut vraiment
valoir le coup d'acheter ce nouvel ipad
ne s'inscrit pour des questions de
longévité parce que c'est un produit
vous allez garder beaucoup plus
longtemps tous les autres modèles moi je
les fasse parce que tout ce qui se
trouve beaucoup trop anciens obsolète
alors effectivement les ipad n'est pas
comme sur les iphone avec des taux de
renouvellement tous les ans voire tous
les deux ans les produits on les garde
plus longtemps trois ans quatre ans
c'est pas comme je le dis un iphone un
modèle pousse l'autre là non un ipad
vous allez le conserver attention
néanmoins il se peut que d'un malouda
beaulieu d'ici au mois de juin de cette
année apple annonce un ipad pro avec un
écran borderless bon avoir un peu par
cette source est question d que fait ça
dit de caméras trou d'aix voir un petit
peu comment tout ça tout est intégré
c'est pas dit que ce soit annoncée mais
si ça elle les attendait un petit peu
anglais tom ipad trop si toutefois vous
vouliez ipad pro parce qu'il pourrait y
avoir un double intérêt le tout premier
c'est que le nouveau produit pour être
vraiment hyper sexy avec de nouvelles
fonctionnalités un nouveau style encore
plus précis dans sa taille vraiment
vraiment vraiment très intéressant et
puis deuxième point surtout que ça peut
faire chuter les prix des ipad pro
actuels donc wait and see si vous voulez
un ipad pro attend dès le mois de juin
est la nouvelle conférence d'apple
d'abonnés haut débit d'ici qui aura lieu
le 6 juin prochain
si je me trompe pas sur la date
normalement c'est bien ça et si vous
voulez un ipad un peu plus standard
l'ipad de 2018 fera vraiment la faire
paul un peu tout ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui sur ses ipad et dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez est ce que
vous avez en projet dans lâcheté 1
est-ce que vous avez déjà un ipad est ce
que vous en avez déjà eu ça pourrait
vous intéresser est ce que vous êtes
allergique
ipad est ce que vous avez pas du tout
ces produits est ce qu ont préféré les
modèles de samsung d'autres tablettes
les blagues de huawei très sympa j'ai pu
tester la dernière le dernier dernière
tablette pro de huawei franchement elle
est bien alors j'ai encore quelques
petits doutes mais faudra utiliser et
l'essayer un peu plus tard mais en
attendant sur le concept sur le principe
sans le prix tout ça je trouve plutôt
cool mark et moi tout ça en commentaire
comme d'habitude véritable essai des
jolies pousse à vous abonner parce qu'on
parlait toujours plus toujours mieux de
teck sur des produits apple samsung sont
de la robotique sur plein de choses n'y
a pas que des téléphones n'y a pas que
des tablettes
il ya plein d'autres choses et ça on va
en parler toujours plus d'ailleurs mais
thébaux aussi en commentaire et dites
moi ce que vous voudriez voir comme
sujet ce que vous voulez qu'on traite
vous ne marquez tout ça d'ici là soyez
ça je vous donne rendez vous très très
très bientôt je vous embrasse
n'oubliez pas vous êtes les meilleurs et
à bientôt
[Musique]